welcome to our research fellowship
presentation meeting
if you are joining us for the first time
today i am deepshavas the bioinfomatrix
community manager
at pine biotech the research project
program
has been designed to help young
researchers
and students take advantage of the
bioinformatics resources
for analysis of complex high throughput
life science data
and become versed in bioinformatics
this program offers you to participate
in real and cutting-edge bioinformatics
research
and be part of a renowned bioinformatics
the research fellowship is a program for
independent research projects where we
learn
about the application of bioinformatics
to big high throughput or mix data
mastering the tbio info cloud-based
bioinformatics platform
understanding of ngs data expertise with
biostatistical tools and machine
learning concepts
effective use of functional annotation
and biological interpretation
cutting-edge research with supervised
and unsupervised
multi-omics integration apply
tools to interpret meaningful insights
and start your own bioinformatics ngs
project
and these are the different research
areas that we focus on
like oncology biology neuroscience
microbiome and agriculture data science
and machine learning
i would like to invite dr mohit mazumdar
our omics logic
project guide at pine biotech to talk
more about the bioinformatics research
dr mazumdar over to you thank you
okay hello everyone so let me share my
screen
uh yeah so today i wanted to talk to you
all
about uh the
research fellowship program and what we
are actually doing in this program
in the term in in in the sense of
projects
and the research that we are conducting
with
our fellows here who have joined this
meeting as well
so to give to give you a background
over the past 20 years there has been a
phenomenal growth
in the adaptation of high throughput
technologies like
next generation sequencing in research
biotechnology
and clinical practice so these
technologies
uh produced exponential uh growth
of publicly available omics data right
so this trend produce has produced many
exciting challenges that could be solved
that could be solved
by extracting this sort of information
and knowledge from this data
so for example to learn about the nature
of
malignant processes and the relationship
between clinical between clinical
phenotypes
and their molecule and their molecular
drivers
that's an example so this process of
posting relevant data
for pressing research needs has also
been
accelerating including a major increase
in public sharing of omics data
during this ongoing pandemic
so importantly this sharing of data is
just not about the
biological phenomenon but in depth view
of actually you know what's going on
so at a molecular level if you want to
understand this data
which we are talking about and analyzing
every day
is called or referred as the omics data
so today i wanted to also give you an
example in the context of
maybe precision oncology or precision
medicine
so precision medicine aims to empower
clinicians
especially to predict the most
appropriate course of action
for you know patients with complex
diseases
such as uh cancer diabetes
uh cardiomyopathy kovi 19
so so with a pro with this progressive
you know interpretation
of clinical data and then
molecular data and then genomic factors
that are at play in many of these
diseases
so accumulation of all this data
and more effective and personalized
medical treatments could be anticipated
right for
many disorders because we are not just
talking about
one kind of information we are
collecting different kind of omics
information
along with the clinical information
along with uh
epidemiological information and then
we we are trying to predict a right path
a right path for a patient care
so this understanding of uh you know
different types of omics
uh including like patients metabolomics
and their genetic makeup in conjugations
in conjugation with clinical data
will definitely and significantly lead
to you know determining
uh predepositions diagnostics
prognostics and predictive biomarkers
and this path which we are taking in for
precision medicine
is ultimately going to provide optimal
and personalized care for this diverse
and uh you know targeted chronic and
acute
diseases and this diverse population for
for a diverse population right so
most of this data that you that is
generated uh
are generated randomly because it uses a
high throughput system
and it is generated at a very high speed
right
and then to do analysis of this data
it requires uh complex computational
data processing
so that is one of the challenges
that anyone any biologist or anyone
interested
in learning these sort of omics data has
to
overcome so uh this process
or the process of a procedure to
generate a structured data set
a structured data set where we have
labels
where we understand the um
the where we have removed the artificial
artifact artifacts and understand the
biological
uh uh connection of data
that have been generated for a
particular particular experiment
right so sorry
so it is important now to understand
this kind of structured data
the next step after you have processed
this data
and to be able to visualize this and to
be statistically understand what is the
important
importance of this uh experiment or the
data set that you are analyzing yourself
so in the context of you know current
pandemic
so scientists around the globe are
working to understand this noble
coronavirus
how it spreads how it evolves
and also the genetic sequencing has
provided enormous insights
so since saskov2 virus is a is an
rna virus it naturally uh acquires
mutation right
so this nature so this mutations that
are happening at a really uh
fairly consistent rate
uh many of these mutations uh that are
happening within the uh
virus uh i mean in in the context of
biology
so they do not they they
may may not be important in the context
of
you know the infection
but those uh particular uh mutations
like different type of mutations that we
are getting information about
could be important for you know
understanding that how
it spreads or how it is affecting or
infecting
individuals globally so drawing those
relationships
out of uh you know different data sets
is some of the things that we do that
in that includes like going through
scientific literature
then uh looking at the sequences looking
and finding those
mutations which are like really connects
with the population
data with the with the spread of what we
are seeing
so finding those kind of correlations
and then tracing them back to the
structure
is uh one of the research that we kind
of focus on for infectious diseases
and you know this next generation
sequencing and today we wanted to talk a
lot about next generation sequencing
data because
uh one of the major objective of this
sort of training is to go through
and understand this uh hugely available
uh publicly available data sets so this
is a
really powerful tool for tracking those
mutations as i said
genomics and uh even monitoring for
patients
infection progression and immune
responses such as these
so one of the key benefits of ngs is to
ability its
is its ability to scale so for instances
sequencing system can simultaneously
sequence more than 100 000 samples
but again the challenge itself is about
is is to able to understand and analyze
that
huge amount of information and that's
why we call it like
big data
so talking about the ngs technology and
how it connects
and you know in the context of the
current pandemic and not just in the
context of the current pandemic but in
the in
context of infectious diseases this this
technology is really helpful
for understanding diseases such as ebola
tuberculosis
and papillomavirus so all those
infectious disease uh problems uh
are really uh uh
can help these ngs data sets are helping
really
uh us to gain deeper insights into these
uh
these diseases and their progression so
um
and this sort of data is really widely
available so millions of sequence you
saw thousands of genomes that are
available
in these repositories and these
repositories contain
are from like ncbi and other uh
joint genomic uh integration databases
are there
so these databases are also growing
really uh fast and at an exponential
speed
so in the end in the context of
bioinformatics research and
bioinformatics research project
uh so what can be done with this data
so anyone including you here can
find a relevant data set can find a
relevant data set
and learn how to analyze this data
data using different tools and
techniques learning about the research
method
to analyze and discover new things and
explore new ways
finding and gaining insight from this
data and apply data science techniques
so one of the
major uh you know challenge with this
data that i've been talking about
for quite some time now is that that how
do we find
patterns and gain insight and learn
about the
you know about the biomarkers that we
talked about
learn about the patterns that would give
us
you know cl that could help us classify
patient groups
so we use uh several ai or
multiple ai or machine learning
algorithms
such as use of support vector machines
logistic
regression and looking for the factors
and discriminant analysis we can do to
classify two groups
then we draw decision trees that helps
us
you know again classify uh
unsupervised or supervised techniques so
random forest is another method linear
regression native base
so these are different types of uh you
know machine learning
uh methods that are used to find and
gain insights from this sort of data
and in the end we kind of are exploring
the scientific knowledge that we are
extracting
and then we are trying to find decide or
predict
and in the end what we are trying to do
is uh
trying to connect this connect the dots
to complete and
you know find uh find a solution or
complete a story or to complete a
research project
so to talk more about how we do this
and what we do in in a research
fellowship program
and how we kind of go from one step to
another
successfully finding data and converting
that data
into finding information from the data
through these complex methods
with ease i would like to pass it on
pass it back to pipsha
to talk more about the program thank you
thank you so much dr mohit i will be
sharing my screen right now
and while i'm sharing my screen uh you
all can
see a poll this poll is to help us
know more about you so we have
three questions the first question is
we would like to know more about you
please share your research interest
with us so you can put in any of your
research
interest here and if you find that it is
not mentioned
in these five points you can also
mention that
in the chat box the second question is
have you done
any binder matrix internship before
and the third question is have you
worked on any bioinformatics projects
before
so as i continue with the slides please
continue
putting in your votes
so talking about the research fellowship
program
it is typically offered for either three
months
or six months if you have already
completed
any online training or have a degree in
bioinformatics or are well
versed in bioinformatics we then
recommend
the three-month research fellowship
program
this program will help you develop a
research proposal
and complete the analysis independently
while working with a mentor
and support from like-minded
collaborators
if you are new to buying for matrix
and you want to learn as well as develop
a research proposal or conduct an
independent research project with a
potential poster
or publication then the six month
research fellowship program
is for you in this program you will get
training
access to ongoing programs and the
support of a community
as you prepare and complete the research
project
now i would want to introduce you to a
few resources that we have
developed for our research fellows and
our biopho matrix community in general
so these include training materials
research articles as well as research
projects that you can learn from
the first resource we recommend everyone
to start with
is the introduction to bioinformatics
course
this course starts with a survey that
helps us learn
more about your interests and then the
course
explains to you the different
applications of bioinformatics
in life science research in the past
few weeks we have also been working on
to launch a few blog posts related to
bioinformatics
internship opportunities application of
ngs in malaria research as well as a
guide on finding
omics data for alzheimer's disease and
shortly i will
show you how to access all of these
resources
by signing into edu dot
t hyphen bio dot info you can find the
link
to the website or the educational portal
in the chat box edu dot t hyphen bio dot
info
our team has also designed some new
projects for our research fellows to
learn from
before they can start working on their
own project like the ebola virus
covid19 liver cancer and tuberculosis
every month our team adds new example
projects taken from
peer-reviewed publications on different
areas of bioinformatics research
so please start by creating
a free account on edu.t bio info
and now let us go back to the website to
view some of these projects
so this is the edu dot t hyphen bio dot
info website
once you come to this website you will
notice that there
are a lot of courses then there are
projects that you all can start
exploring
the registration to this website is free
and you can register either via your
email id
or by using any of the social media
accounts
and once you are logged in you would
notice under courses there is a course
called
introduction to buying for matrix and
that was a course which i was talking
about earlier
this course will give you an
overview of the different ways the
bioinformatics courses
are taught here it's an asynchronous
course which means that
it's a course for self-study that you
can take
at your own pace and time
and to introduce this course there is a
video that you can go through so i will
also be posting the direct link
to this course right in the chat box
again
so it is necessary if you are intending
to join
the program or if you are just new to
this community to start with the
introduction to bi-informatics course
as it will give you an overview of the
different applications of bi-informatics
we recommend this course for
both beginners as well as for
researchers and faculty who are part of
our bioinformatics community
so you see there's an intro survey and
then there are different lectures which
are divided into separate sections
so as you go through this course you
will also learn about the other
asynchronous courses that you can again
take from here
and see how the module is designed
next coming to the projects that we were
talking about
so you see that here are the
tuberculosis project the covid19 project
liver cancer
and these are not the only projects if
you scroll down you will find
different projects related to oncology
as well
even neuroscience so please take a look
through these different projects
and the third resource which i was
showing you is
our blog platform so this blog
is where we create articles which i just
showed you
some images of so for example
this is a very interesting article on
the different bifurmatics opportunities
that are available so please feel free
to
explore the blog section as well and all
of this is available
freely to everyone who is a member of
the educational portal and i would also
want to
invite you all to go ahead and be part
of our
social media groups and communities and
the reason you should be part of a
community like ours is because
you are not only getting um
to know a community of students but you
can see
the researchers as well as faculty
and uh those who are working at
different bioinformatics companies
cancer research institutes
all over the world who are part of this
community
so this is a free resource and this is
open for everyone to go ahead
and take part in so please go ahead and
join our groups we also have a group
on facebook as well so you can take part
in either of these
groups and community and
also share your ideas and your views
with
everyone else now let's go back to the
presentation i hope that
if you have not already created an
account
you would be creating an account right
now and we would be getting started
so now i would like to explain the
research fellowship
process with you and the goal as we know
is to come up with our own independent
project
so how does this step-by-step
process work so
this entire process starts with the very
basics the
introductory courses that i have shown
you
so these courses are based on not just
introduction to bind for matrix but also
other omits topics
like transcriptomics which will
introduce you to ngs or rna-seq data
analysis
metagenomics epigenetics and more
so this will build up your idea about
what omics logic
is so you learn the logic from these
basic courses
then you go ahead and get familiar with
the projects
why is it helpful the projects will help
you to learn
and to see how others have
approached a biological problem and
solve that problem so their approach
will help you
get a better idea of how you should
approach a similar kind of a biological
problem
right and while you're doing step one
and two we recommend you to keep
a journal and how is the journal helpful
you should note down
each and everything you are doing in
that journal so we recommend all of our
research fellows to either
have a google document or
a presentation like i am showing here
where they can record each of the steps
they are doing which means it starts
with
giving a review of the courses they are
doing
it shows that how you are understanding
each of the courses
and our mentor team can guide you
similarly
in case you are not understanding
something and you
would also understand the different uh
problems or the challenges that you're
facing when it comes to developing your
project and it is also very helpful
in case you are from an university or an
organization which requires you to
record
each step of the internship process
now once you're familiar with the
project
and you have an idea of the kind of
projects you would want to get uh
started with
we recommend the literature review now
we have
uh in our experience seen that there are
two sets of
uh students or interns who come in uh
there are a few who already know
what kind of project they would want to
work on and there are others who do not
know
what area they are more interested in
and they might have multiple
interests so the literature review in
that case is very helpful
to get you familiar with the different
research techniques and the different
multi-omics and bioinformatics research
that is going on in that
particular area you may be interested in
so that you can
formulate your own research idea and
then work with your mentor on completing
that project
the fifth step is of course making a
presentation
again like this this exercise is very
important and very soon we will be
seeing our own
research fellows present some of their
projects as well as their progress
who have been a part of this research
fellowship program
for some time or you know longer
so this presentation is going to be
a final presentation where you would be
presenting your full project
and your progress and then in the sixth
step
peer review so this would not only be
reviewed by
our team of mentors but also it would be
reviewed by your peers
and we definitely recommend you to share
it with your friends and family to make
sure that
if there is someone who does not
understand by informatics
your goal in the project is also clear
to them
now moving on we are going to see some
project
presentation and to start with i would
like to
invite our research fellow kalau mari
to go ahead and share his presentation
on subtypes classification of triple
negative breast cancer
kalamari over to you
ah thank you i will share my my screen
sure go ahead good morning everyone
can you see in my screen yes we can see
your screen calamari you can go ahead
okay great i'm going to talk about my
project that is
entitled classification of triple
negative breast cancer lines by gene
expression analysis
of strand membrane proteins using
machine learning algorithms
my name is carlo marie majoralpena just
to talk a little about myself
i'm from kerataron city in mexico and
i'm a phd
student from the program of
biotechnology
at technological monterey and actually
my phd is about the development of
devices for the diagnosis of triple
negative breast cancer so
i have interest in finding
new biomarkers that could improve the
analysis and the diagnosis of this this
type of disease
just in order to have some context about
the triple negative breast cancer it
represents
from 10 to 20 percent of breast cancer
however it is highly heterogeneous so
it's difficult to
diagnose there are several subtypes
and also uh
well the main characteristic of this
type of disease
is that these breast cancers they they
have negative
response to estrogen receptors
progesterone receptors and also
epidermal growth factor receptor as a
result
the the hormonal and the immune
therapies are not very effective
and also a common is commonly an an
aggressive
type of disease so the treatment is
difficult
and early diagnosis is important
in order to have a positive outcome
when you are diagnosed with this disease
so and in order to
to find new biomarkers well
the type of biomarkers i'm interested on
are the
membrane biomarkers because well they
can be used for
for prognostics to know the prognosis
and also
to monitor the development of of
different type of cancer
they also are critical in they play an
important role
in in cellular structure and function
and also
in the proliferation of cancerous cells
and and also they they are
important as a drug target
the pharmaceutical perspective
so for this reason i decided
to generate a question and it says
it is possible to classify breast cancer
cells by gene expression analysis
of strong membrane proteins using
machine learning
and well the hypothesis is that
these breast cancer cell lines can be
classified
in the molecular subtypes using the
expression of these transmembrane
proteins and also
implementing the machine learning
algorithms
and the methodology consists
in when one in an approach the first
approach
is it involves the selection
of transmembrane proteins from
the annotation of the genes that are
present in a data set
then performing some machine learning
analysis
using these genes that are selected
and then validating these
all these genes with with another data
set in order to see
if the machine learning and the genes
are performing
in a proper manner and for the second
approach
in that in this approach the idea is to
select
genes that are useful for the
classification of breast cancer but
that are not necessarily
transmembrane genes and then perform the
the same type of machine learning
analysis and validation
in order to get at the end a list of
transmembrane genes that are common
with both approaches and which could be
analyzed as
candidates for for
diagnosis and
the the two data sets that i
that i use in this project and the first
one is
is based in the article of modeling
precision
uh treatment of breast cancer and the
second one is is a recent
data set that was used for the external
validation and it was
uh it was from a professor from harvard
medical school
here are the the accession numbers
and for the preparation the the first
step was to homogenize the information
present in the data sets
i employed a quantic normalization with
a threshold of five
then the annotation and the selection
and the analysis and everything was
performing the tower bioinformatics
research center the algorithms and all
the analysis
and for the first approach uh
160 genes were annotated as
transmembrane and they were
they were selected and a principal
components analysis was performed
and as you can see there are some of the
groups
are easy to identify according to this
analysis
and well it's important to mention that
the luminal vc and basal bc
they are normal breast cancer they are
not triple negative breast cancer
and the other ones are negative triple
negative breast cancer and
non-malignant then
uh considering that
106 and 6 digits is a large number i
decided to reduce the number of
of genes and for this i
perform a random forest algorithm and
i used the 10 of the
of the data set to test the algorithm
with an accuracy of 83.3 percent
and here is the the criteria
uh and mean decrease accuracy bigger
or lower than two and lower than minus
two and actually i got
four transmembrane genes according to
this filter selection
and as you can see the groups are
are pretty well separated so
this analysis suggests that a
the posterior analysis could provide
interesting results so
i decided to work with the supervised
machine learning analysis
using dimension for the games and
actually the performance
with the first data set wasn't
as as good as expected however well the
number of
samples was reduced so it causes some
difficulties
with the algorithm but during the
validation
using the the second data set
uh with a larger number of samples
to test well the the accuracy was
was improved and actually as you can see
is around 90 90 percent so i think that
these these genes with the machine
learning algorithm
perform well and then
i work in the second approach
and in the second approach i consider
uh 40 14 000
genes from the first data set and and i
also perform
the feature selection using random
forest
and in that case i used an accuracy
larger than 1.2 or smaller than
minus 1.2 because yeah the the number
where lower in comparison to the to the
other
factor selection and i as a result
i got 133 genes
and as you can see with the principal
component analysis
the groups are pretty well separated
just the ones of that are breast cancer
basal breast cancer and luminal brains
consider difficult to separate from the
from the basal and luminal
but in general they look good
so i i perform the supervised machine
learning analysis using dimension genes
and the with the first data set
the the accuracy was was
more was better in that in the
in the previous approach but not
as good as as i as i expected
but during the uh the external violation
with the second data set
the the accuracy was was good was
over 90 percent so
the all these machine learning
with the genes work pretty well and then
after all these analysis i decided to
check from the the first approach using
these 40 genes
from transmembrane proteins and and then
try to find
which genes are shared by the two
approaches
and according to this there were two
transmembrane genes that are shared by
two approaches
so i go these two candidates that
that could be useful for for future
analysis
so as conclusions uh well the machine
learning algorithms
that were used were
good for the classification of breast
cancer cell lines
using the gene expression analysis
in both of the approaches and actually
the support vector machine algorithm
provided
better results in comparison to in
comparison to the
random forest also the machine learning
algorithms
were validated with with an external
data set
and but more more external validation
with other dataset is is recommended
in order to to know if the
if the results are consistent
and also the genes
uh well i obtained two genes that
could be interesting for further
analysis
in in the diagnostic area
and also well it's important to mention
that the
well it did the analysis involve only
the
gene expression so other aspects of
cancer are not considered
also the accuracy of the machine
learning algorithm can be improved
by modifying the selection procedure and
modifying the cutoff value
during the vector selection and also the
transmembrane proteins
need to be confirmed the expression
doesn't
mean that the protein is present in the
cell
so this
information is necessary and well
i was expecting having more than than
two genes but unfortunately
just two to jeans archer with both
approaches
and that's all
thank you for for your attention
thank you so much uh calamari for this
excellent presentation
um does anyone have any question for
calamari
on this project you can ask us in the
chat box
or you can ask actually i have a i
actually have a question
uh calamari could you expand a little
bit more
on uh why you were interested in this
project and what was your previous
experience with bioinformatics and what
have you
learned through this experience
well actually uh well the
i i i had important limitations
with respect to the lab work so i was
trying to find
other ways to complement my my research
that doesn't
involve the use of laboratory facilities
and also well bioinformatically i think
it's a very important tool that could
help in in improving the research
without requiring a
a large amount of of expenditures
with respect of reagents and materials
so
i i had this
interest of implementing bioinformatic
approaches
in order to to make a research more
efficient
considering the limitations of resources
and facilities
and for this reason i was interested
in joining the this research
internship and actually i learned a lot
about the use of of these tools and and
the
i think that the data science
perspective is
is very useful because usually the
courses about bioinformatics they just
uh they just tell you how to use some of
the databases but you don't see
all of that in a in a data science
perspective so i think that
this perspective is very useful and
i i got very interesting results that i
i expect to continue working on
uh one second before we get to those
questions my other question is
so what what are you planning to do with
this project after you're done with this
program
well i would like to to continue with
this project in order to generate some
a paper so i was thinking that maybe it
would be a good idea to continue
working within the internship or to to
[Music]
to yeah to to enter to the internship
again in order to continue with some
parts of the project
in order to to generate a publication
okay thank you calamari here i have a
question from daido it's asking have you
tested
other ml methods such as gbm or xboost
i i i tested i haven't tested
all the machine learning method i just
tested
linear discriminant analysis and
this was the other method that i tested
and the
in comparison to the random forest and
support vector machine the performance
was lower so i decided to
not continue performing this analysis
but yeah i i just tested these three
methods
linear discriminant analysis uh support
vector machine and random forest
maybe in the future i will i will test
other other methods
uh thank you for your question dido and
thank you for answering kalamari we have
one more question from janani and then
we'll move on
uh the question is how did you decide
which aspects of gene expression to
analyze with machine learning
well uh
in in in my case
well the transmembrane proteins were
relevant
because in the type of devices that i'm
i'm working on it's easy to separate the
cells
using these uh distance membrane
proteins so in my case i would well the
focus was
according to the type of project that
i'm developing so
so i think that this is the
the reason why well that i
decide to to take this perspective
yeah uh thank you so much kalam mari and
i would now like to invite sonalika
to go ahead and share her review of the
liver cancer project
so nalika and thank you kalamari
thank you
greeting everybody is my screen visible
yes we can see your screen
okay
[Music]
we cannot hear you clearly your
connection must be
disrupting
hi biksha so maybe we can move on to the
next presentation meanwhile sonatika me
can so i'm sorry that sonalika is having
some trouble
uh regarding her network issue so i
would like to
invite avio bruno to
share his project on identification
characterization and expression analysis
of cell wall related genes
as primary targets for efficient biofuel
production
in sorghum by color so
avio please go ahead
and have you also please make sure to
unmute yourself
hello hello avio yes we can hear you
and also see your screen please go ahead
okay
okay thank you
i'm called bruno uh my presentation is
on identification
calculation and expression analysis of
cellular related genes as primary
targets for efficient biofuel production
in southern black color
i'll not give a background to the study
uh
my as i had prepared this presentation
with focus of
only providing providing feedback on the
progress that i've made
i'm having four objectives i'm going to
present
mainly the progress on one objective on
the fourth objective which i
am looking at calculation of
transcription pattern of sodium
cellular related genes and a moisture
stress and under
differing developmental growth stages
under the deferring developmental growth
stages i'm having three
three different data sets uh
uh three different data sets from
uh looking at transcription data at
vegetative and reproductive stage of
slogan
so from the first data set it was from a
study by makita
ital 2015 where transcription data was
taken
at a reproductive reproductive stage
mainly taking transcription data from
speculator and stem
and from seed at average maturity
and here they collected they had
transcription data on 10
10 different samples for the second data
set
transcript transcription data was taken
from a 20 day old leaf
and they they had 10 srnf
sria srif the third data set
looked into a transcription data from
a vegetative and reproductive stage
on sub subset of the study 2
of style of the same study and
the the interest was to look at gene
expression analysis under
various biotic stresses with focus on
drought
and this uh the data was obtained from
uh
from dougas 2011 where
uh sra sra sequence data was collected
at uh at seedling stage
from shoot and roots under
under four different treatments i'll
give
the presentation will mainly provide
analysis for
subsection 2 which is 4.2
with this study what was done was that
the
seeds of a single genotype
[Music]
instead of one genotype that is a bt
btx 623 was planted
was planted and and was planted
and once after the third day once they
have already
once the seeds are already germinated
the seeds the seedlings were transferred
into
uh a control chamber room and kept him
there till the eighth day
and on the eighth day the the
uh the uh the seedlings were put into
uh the seedlings were put into four
different groups
and in group one uh the seedlings were
sprayed with abscisic acid
abscisic acid and group 2 was spread
with
sodium hydroxide group 3 was
spread by polyethylene glycol and
and the last the the last group was
sprayed with uh
with water basically sodium
sodium hydroxide acted as a control for
abscisic acid
and water acted as a control for poly
polyethylene glycol
so uh after the treatment uh
uh i arrange a transcript
where where where
where where were obtained from root and
shoot
from from brutus shoot
from root and shoot with
each group having three replicates
as you can see from uh from my diagram
so i i performed an analysis
uh basically the analysis that i've
conducted up to now is more for
an exploratory and exploratory uh
kind of analysis so i
i did a gene expression analysis where
the transcript were mapped onto the uh
uh where were mapped using multi
uh baltic tutti and
i from the trans from the expression
analysis
that was uh that i did
i obtained uh over 24
24 000 genes and these were designated
as
us locks subject and then trna
as us have summarized us
summarize that summarize summarize on it
on the slide so
at the beginning i first i first
did a test i first performed a test
a test a test analysis where a subset
a subset of a subset of
of six sra files
were analyzed and these uh these six
sra files were from
well from two two different treatments
that is sodium hydroxide and pig
sodium hydroxide and peg and i observed
that
from the principal component analysis
that i conducted
they were nicely separated into two
groups based on the
business based on the treatment
condition and
similarly i did a cluster
test analysis and the same observation
was observed
same absorption was observed i i
tried to assess the relationship between
samples from the same treatment
uh so this is from this is from
sodium white i hydroxide and peg and i
observed that there is a
uh there's a strong relationship between
the
between the gene expression part and
other day uh
between the gene expression pattern of
of
of
of samples of samples that were treated
uh that were treated that are the same
that had the same treatment which was
that the data is
the quality of the data is quite good
so i i went ahead and looked into
and i looked into the the distribution
the distribution of the of the data set
on box plot and observe that there's
some
there's some some outliers or uh
some outliers in all the in
all the in all the samples but
what i observe is that the the median of
the median of all data where were
where uh were quite related and they
and the an extent of the variation uh
extent of the variation in the
under the different treatment conditions
were quite related
so i went ahead and now looked into the
all
all the 24 sra files
and perform a similar kind of analysis
that i did with six
ssr files and observed that uh
i observed uh using the principal
component analysis i observed
i observed uh uh
i observed four different sets of
clusters
of four different sets of clusters and
when i performed
a dendrogram when i performed at uh
when i went ahead and did this on on
dental gram
i observed a similar trend the similar
observation that
i that that the principal component
revealed was also revealed here and
we had two uh it showed two major
clusters
two major clusters basically uh this
split the data based on the uh based on
the
plant based on the plant organ so this
uh this major cluster basically are
shoots
and this uh this these clusters
are basically roots and in between here
i've got uh
four clusters which are which are
separated based on the treatment
the kind of treatment so from this i
observe that
i can really get very interesting uh
genes differentially expressed genes
first of all between between the organs
and and among us the treatment
among us the the among us they treat
among us the four
among us the four types of treatment so
i'm hoping that uh
with this data i can get very
interesting uh
very interesting genes that relates to
cell wall
uh uh that list that relates to
cell wall uh data related to cellular
plant cell wall so i did i went ahead
and looked at
i looked at the nature of
variation the nature of variation
on the box plot i still observed
the the extent of the the extent of the
the variation
under the different under the different
plant organ
and treatment level were almost the same
where were almost the same but
from this from the root i observed
relatively
that there could be some outliers that i
that
that needs to be looked into and
probably trim off
but the shoots looks relatively okay
i i my focus i
i i went ahead and tried to look into
uh finding out
which genes are expressed differently on
the day
and under under the different treatment
under the different treatment different
types of treatment
and different organs i
this is the pipeline i followed
unfortunately
i did i performed this analysis and
the output that i obtained uh
the the folders were empty and i failed
to understand where the
challenge was so i from the analysis
that i've conducted this
is this is where this is where i ended
but uh
the the expression the the genes that i
uh that are indicated in my gene
expression table
they're in terms of location locks
locks and other and other types of names
so
once once i obtain the genes that are
differentially expressed
the genes that are differentially
expressed i can cite for the
the gene names from from the sorghum
gene database
and once i obtain those genes i believe
i should be able to go
and perform my gene ontology analysis
and try to identify those genes that are
strongly related with a cell wall
that are strongly related that data
related to
cell wall that participate in
in cell wall cell wall regulation
and another challenge that i faced was
that
in the uh um uh
for for the subsection one where i'm
looking at uh
where i'm looking at gene expression
under different growth stages i'm having
three different sets of files
i i have no idea how
these three different sets of file can
be uh
can be combined as one in order to
in order to have as in order to conduct
perform analysis as one as
one set of experiments so
that's why my challenges that i faced
during the
yeah thank you thank you it's really
exciting to see the progress
with your project that you're getting
some insight so thank you for sharing
that
about the technical part of your
question how to combine multiple
uh data sets together all you need to do
really is just to create
one single table with all of those links
and then use
ncbi upload tool so that you will get
all of them
combined together what you probably need
to consider afterwards however is how to
normalize the data
so that it actually is consistent maybe
removing some batch effects
and so these are things that we can
address in our next meeting one-on-one
to kind of discuss
some of these challenges but i think
overall uh you're off to a great start
it would be really exciting to see uh
what else you
find in your data but so far i think it
looks really good
thank you
thank you so much have you and thank you
yeah
so now i would like to uh invite
sonalika back
i think her issues are solved so so
nadika you can go ahead
and share your project again
good evening everybody i am really sorry
for the glitch
i am sanalika ray currently pursuing
masters in bioinformatics from punjab
university chandigarh
today i am here to discuss the major
findings of hepatocellular carcinoma
which is abbreviated as
fcc and i would be shedding light on the
risk factors involve gene mutations
treatments and what are the different
scopes of research in this field
so what is hcc it is the most common
form of liver cancer
it is a second leading cause of cancer
death in the in the world and there are
between 6 lakh to 1 million new
hcc cases in the world annually so this
is clearly still an important area of
basic science clinical science and drug
development
the highest incidence and mortality of
hcc are
observed in east asia africa europe and
in the us
now i would like to discuss few of the
risk
factors which are associated with scc so
patients with
a
consumption are have the major sb
virus or hepatitis c virus ah
then nafld
hi sonalika we have lost you again
nash that is non-alcoholics the
polymorphisms in the in these three
genes which i mentioned
hi sonalika uh we are keeping on like
losing you
um i mean it's not very clear to us
fashion sec incidents
another risk factors are statuses from
by
hi sonalika can you hear me can you
please
yes yeah yeah so we keep on continue to
lose you so your connection is like
fluctuating
maybe you can go a little slow because
we kind of mixed out on a lot of the
things while you are explaining the risk
factors thank you
hi sonalika i think that uh because of
your issue
we would be looking at your project in
the next time
i mean we cannot hear you at all so i
would like to pass it on to the next
person so in our next meeting uh you can
go ahead
and again address everybody
so thank you so much sunalika i'm sorry
that your connection is not working out
and i would like now like to invite
fazan ahmed
to go ahead and give us a review of his
progress so far so farzan is
joining us uh just since the last week
so what we are going to do is see how he
has progressed and he's also going to
introduce himself
to us so farzan please go ahead
and also please unmute yourself thank
you
so can you hear me yeah we can hear you
and i hope you can see my screen as well
right yeah
we can see your screen as well okay so
my name is
um i am a final year student
in btec bioinformatics at amity
university norada
so i just joined this program about
10 days ago so at this point
i'm really just going through the
courses i'm trying to get a
grasp of what i can do and what is
available
okay so i started off with the
introduction to
bioinformatics course um where
i learned the basic concepts
uh involved in bioinformatics such as
whole transcript what is available over
here
and what we base
what we are basically doing in
bioinformatics and
why it's important
so there are many different areas of
study within this field as well such as
and one of the fields in which i'm
interested in
in personalized medicine and hopefully
once i'm done with the courses i can
pursue a project related
to personalized medicine um
and over here we basically consider
genomic and metabolic data
to provide the to provide a suitable
treatment to a group of patients
and in personalized medicine we also
look at diagnosing a disease or a
condition
um at an earlier stage
so we can treat it on time on this
especially useful
in cancer and this is enabled by the
vast
amount of amount of data which is the
genomic data that is available
the other areas where we can also apply
it is
in environmental science we can apply it
in microbial communities which is
known as the metagenomics
so this is basically the summary of
what i went through in introduction to
bioinformatics
the second course that i'm also pursuing
now is epigenetics um this is a course
that i've actually never studied um
so this is the first time i'm actually
going through
what epigenetics really is i've heard of
the term but i never really
studied it in depth so it's exciting for
me to
see this um i just started this course a
few days back actually
and so far i just learned that it's a
field that studies interactions between
genes
and products that bring phenotypes into
existence
and this is the field that has been
linked to
this epigenetics is actually linked to
mechanisms
that uh affect the
stability and the folding of the dna
um i've also i'm also at the same time
exploring the t
bio info platform that i
that i recently gained access to
apart from that i've also i'm also
planning on starting the transcriptomics
course
and maybe longer we make some progress
and hopefully
plan a project that
that is useful
so that's it for now actually
thank you so much fazan thank you for
giving us this review
and it's good to see your progress in
the last 10 days
so now i would want to invite swati to
talk about her progress so swati has
been already a part of one of our omits
logic
programs and she has some experience
utilizing the tools
so she has also joined the research
fellowship program
to work on her own independent project
so we will be hearing from swathi so
swadhi please go ahead
yeah i hope i'm audible and my screen is
visible
sure swati yes we can see you and also
hear
you see your screen thank you please go
ahead
so to introduce myself um
i'm swati third year undergraduate
i'm studying at mit university
pursuing bioengineering i'm very very
interested in pursuing bioinformatics
for
my highest studies as well i don't have
any research experience in
bioinformatics
but i have taken a summer training
at pine bio and i wish to pursue a
project too
with this internship opportunity so i'll
just be sharing
um what i have covered so far in the
course
all right um so
i covered the um
r and python bioinformatics course
modules
so it started off with how
we import various tables excel files
and csv files into both r
and python i
learned to split data as a data frame
and also in the form of a matrix
so the next part of this module was
processing of the data which basically
means that most of the times in the data
there are
any values basically empty values or
zero values
which interfere with the analysis
methods
so it's important to get rid of this
before running your pipeline
um so some of the theory that was
covered
in these modules were basic theory on
dna structure
and function and of course uh the first
step in the central dogma
which is replication uh the course also
talked about
how uh kinase so cdks
um play an important role in controlling
initiation of
the replication process and how various
uh proteins are involved in the
elongation and termination of this
very extensive process as well
um the highlight for me
of both these courses were learning
about
bioconductor which basically offers
various libraries like biostring and a
cipher which was completely new
to me uh so as far as i have learned
they are used for memory efficient
string containers
string matching algorithms and other
utilities for
manipulation of large biological
sequences or sets of sequences
as a part of an assignment and exercise
in the course
i use these libraries to find
length of a given dna sequence the
frequency of the bases in the sequence
and also the reverse complement of or
the sequence
yeah that's my progress so far thank you
thank you so much swati so now i would
like to
thank all of our research fellows who
took the time
to talk about their progress and share
with
us what they have done so far and also
talk about their
projects so what we do from time to time
the research fellowship program
is not just a program where you come and
do
your own research project or get
training what we want to do
is enable you to not only prepare that
research project but take it further
so we want to enable you we want to make
sure that
your research project is getting the
word of the mouth so we utilize our
social media channels here you can see
simai is one of our research fellows she
recently
completed her fellowship program and her
project
and we have featured her in this blog
post
that gives her access to a wider
audience who can learn
about her project similarly we also have
de lara
who has joined along with simai they
both are from the bachelor university in
turkey
and we keep on featuring students like
them who perform
and do well in a program like this so
the research fellowship program
not only comes with a project that you
design on your own
but there is also a certification that
you receive at the end
of this course which states
how you have performed during this
entire period of three months six months
or any other period that you are
choosing to do the research fellowship
so i welcome you to go ahead and check
out
and also there are other posts on our
blog
which i had mentioned earlier where you
can see why
other participants are recommending
these programs
and i want to again continue to invite
you to go ahead
and join our channel and now i have
a last poll for all of you
that i would be launching in a minute
so if you are intending to join the
research fellowship or you have just
joined right now you can see the poll
which asks you a question what is your
expectation from this research
fellowship training
then the second question is how many
hours per week can you dedicate to this
training this is very
important when you are starting to work
on your own research project
and what are your future goals whether
you want
to work in the industry which is a
bi-informatics industry for a company
or you're looking forward to work in
academia or if you have
any other goals so please put in your
bold result
that way and the fourth question
is what did you think of today's session
so please
go ahead and share your results and i
will quickly
check the chat box
so there are a few questions on how can
i join the research fellowship program
so the first step to join the research
fellowship program
is to sign up for the program so as the
poll is going on i will go ahead
and make sure that i can
show you how to join this program so i
hope that
you all can see my stream so this is the
link
to join the program so
there are also scholarship opportunities
for students who
are in need of scholarships so we do
have a few scholarship opportunities
and i would be sending you the links to
those scholarship opportunities
after this session and you can also
reach out to me marketing at find out
bio
in case you have any specific question
regarding joining
this program so the research fellowship
program
is open not only for individual students
in fact
you can also join with your peers and
work on a group
project right now the project that i
showed you on alzheimer's are by
a student who are working on in a group
along with a researcher
they are together collaborating on that
alzheimer's project so let us go back
to the blog and take a look at it so
maybe
we can go through it together and i will
be able to show you
how that is going on so all of these
projects
or any of these projects you can either
do on your own
along with the mentor support that we
would be providing
and going forward you can also
collaborate with
others so there is a question if some
research project is
going to be published who will be the
author
so in this research projects you are the
one
you are the author of these projects
because what we are helping you do
is come up with your own project so you
are going to be the authors
while the rest of the things that could
be uh
our team like your mentor could be a
co-author in that project
but publication is something which is a
very long drawn out cost
process so in three months or six months
it is not always possible to come up
with a full fledged publication
so what we try to do first
is to make sure that you can come up
with a project like you saw that
kalamari has presented
or avio has presented a project which
you can then work towards a publication
and often the challenge is
to find the right data sets or to find
the right steps of analysis and that
is where most of your time will go in in
figuring out
in the next three months or six months
like how to
make sure that you're getting everything
right for the project so i've put the
link to this
omits project omix blog post
in the chat box
and i will also be answering a few of
the questions so there is a question
from
faria she's asking can a student of
undergrad biotech apply for this
fellowship or should we
wait for the completion of her bsc so
right now just taking an example of the
alzheimer's project
this project is being done by two
students who
are in a high school level so they both
are high school students
andres and netra and they are doing this
project
so this project will give you an
understanding
of the kind of data sets that they're
using the approach that they have taken
to do this project and this actually is
open source so any of you can create an
account on edud by
for portal and read about this project
so you would see what kind of
publications they have been using
and what they are trying to achieve with
this project so
anyone starting from a high school
to any kind of post graduation post doc
level can come and join the research
fellowship program we have participants
who join us from all over the world
who come from different educational
backgrounds so everyone is welcome to
join
and as i showed you while i was
presenting earlier we follow that
step-by-step process where we start with
the very basic courses
and go in a step-by-step process where
you learn
about the logic learn about the data
learn where you can get that kind of
data
identify projects which are similar to
yours do literature review
find the kind of project topic that you
would want to work in
along with your mentor so this is a
program that comes with a full mentor
support so you work
with someone from our team
who would be able to work on this
project
so hello farida
uh regarding your application if you're
already a part of another program
and you still want to apply for this
scholarship so we will be having
like a one-on-one meeting with you again
and
decide whether that is something that we
can offer for you
so please take your time to go through
all of these free resources that are
available to you
please go through the introduction to
bioinformatics course
and if you are applying for
the research fellowship program what we
would
want to learn more about you is like
what is your area of
interest so doing the introduction to
bind for matrix course
is going to be very helpful because the
intro survey will tell us a lot about
what you want to do so this program is
not about
the projects that we are offering but it
is about what you are interested in
pursuing not only
right now but also in the future so
please feel free to join us and if there
are
no more questions so i would like to
thank everyone for attending today's
session
and welcome you all again to join our
programs
and follow us on our social media so
thank you everybody
for joining us today and have a great
week
you